welcome to the recruitment roller
coaster podcast my name is heam Aus
today I'm joined by Laura Briggs who is
the founder of Laura Briggs recruitment
who are an independent specialist
accountancy recruitment business Laura
has worked in recruitment for over five
years and has always worked within the
accountancy space Laura thank you for
joining me thank you how are you I'm
well yeah really good to be here
good as an as an avid listener of the
recr roller coaster podcast is that is
that weird for you to be like okay I'll
listen to this and then now you're a
guest it's the closest I think I'll ever
get to being a
celebrity no I think look there's
there's no barriers to entry to be on
this podcast I think it's all about
having a place where people can hear
different stories right nice but we're
always like to start which you should
know how did Laura Briggs enter the word
of recruitment let let's start there
yeah ease me into it um so I I actually
trained in nutrition and I was a
nutritionist for babies and children in
London for about three four years and I
just got to the stage where I was sick
of public sector it's a really it's it's
a crap place to be really if you're
driven and you want to go places um so I
got into a bit of a rup and I ended up
going to a careers coach and I said I
don't I don't want to study I don't want
to go back and study I don't have any
transferable skills but I like people
and I really want to make some money and
she was pretty much said what about
recruitment or you could be an estate
agent and I thought I could be a
recruiter and nobody around me thought I
could do it like everyone was like Laura
you're not a recruiter you'll be
terrible at this but I threw caution to
the wind I went to read they snapped me
up in their accountancy team um and yeah
kind of went from there okay why did the
people around you why do they think you
w't be good at good at it because I
think there's a sort of a cliche of what
a salesperson is like maybe a bit pushy
you know I'm I'm confident in a social
sense but when it comes to sort of
business you know I I just you know I'd
worked in an NHS Nutrition department
before I hadn't done anything of the
sort and it did seem a bit random um but
that's the thing I think you know
there's not one kind of person who can
do recruitment recruitment's you know a
service and you can do it many many
different ways so I think I just have
some of the soft skills that obviously
make me successful
how how old was you if you don't
remember me asking at that point when
you changed career basically it was 2014
so would have been
26 27 let's talk about that how how
difficult was that cuz like you know we
all have we all have this Vision in our
head that when I'm 26 I want to be here
what you know what I mean and I think
that takes a lot for you to be like you
know what actually I'm going to like
that a lot of people don't like you're
in recruitment now right so you talk
people go through this that you speak to
but how I don't know how was that how
did you come to the conclusion that you
know what actually I need I need a
change and there isn't some I'm not
happy with my current circumstances I
think it helped that I sort of felt like
I didn't have many options so I felt
like I you know was a clean slate but
the thing with recruitment is that I
don't know whether the time moves faster
or because you can you can do well so
quickly you know it's not like other
jobs where you have to climb the ranks
you have to become a manager you have to
do things that way um that now I'm
sitting here what 33 and I feel like
I've been doing recruitment all my life
I I've only done it six years and if I
just done six years in any other job I
feel like I might potentially be at
middle manager level probably not um but
here I I have I have my own business you
know it's just totally different yeah
fair enough no I just respect that
because I think a lot of people they
they would wouldn't have changed and
they wouldn't have done anything right
so I I respect that a lot and I think I
think that's what I experienced when I
first got my first sales job before that
I did all different things from
delivering pizzas to working in retail
or whatever but when you get that real
first taste that actually you get
rewarded and Merit on your hard work and
you're in complete control of that and
you never had that before it's like all
right
okay definitely up yeah I'm definitely I
can do anything now I can do anything
yeah literally so okay so then obviously
joined one of the the big brands in
recruitment Reed so just give us a bit
of context so I have so my only when I
joined recruitment I joined a small
business and my perception of readed was
I go on to to read obviously find CV so
there's a jobboard
element but actual read recruiters there
was some that recruited insurance which
is the space I recruited in I just
thought it was really High Street like
that was my perception so like people
walk in you get Walkins all that is that
is that what it was like totally I think
it's almost looking back I think it's a
cushion landing at Reed accountancy was
one of the best teams the most
successful teams in the business so I
was training with a manager who'd been
there you know for about 30 years um and
I think that helped but also they had
the biggest database they had a great
sort of training package and I think the
only thing that they were fighting
against was the fact they had this real
High Street name um and so what they
tried to do to differentiate us was have
an accountancy team who did sort of
salaries up to 35k and then a fin team
who did those sort of more senior
accountancy roles um but all it caused
was a lot of sort of intern infighting
and yeah it was it was really messy so I
think that's one of the things that sort
of sort of made me made me leave but
yeah the High Street thing you were
always fighting against try you know
trying to be seen as somebody who knew
what they were talking about and knew
they were a specialist um yeah I I don't
know re Reed is well known and I think
that plays in its favor but it probably
doesn't have the same Kudos as like a
Rober half or something in terms of
account was it um just for context and
so you worked at read for how long is it
like two and uh three and a half years
three and a half years sorry yeah three
and a half years and then was it perm
that you did or was it all perm all perm
yeah yeah why why do you think why is it
you think that that high is it for me
what comes to mind for me is instantly
people think it's like super
transactional and like the quality isn't
as high basically from like from that
comes with the high
Street like reputation is is that what
it is or what what was it you was always
trying to convince people that you
wasn't well it was different for me
because
I you know about our County practice and
how that differs to Industry no so
industry is when you have a company and
they have their own accountant who does
their accounts but an accountancy firm
is a firm of accountants who do accounts
for like business like me for
example yeah so you got like internal
what yeah like internal internal
external yeah yeah yeah cool that's it
so I'd been there for about a year I
think and I hated cold calling you know
for anyone who's thinking I couldn't be
a recruiter I hate cold calling I was
absolutely terrible um and they but they
saw in me that I I had other skills so I
was really detail driven and they always
used to say if you give Laura a job she
will fill it like even the difficult
ones but I just couldn't pick up the
phone and talk to somebody why why let's
just because it's terrifying I just and
I didn't know what to say they'd they'd
always get the gatekeeper you know they
they'd never even even if there was a
job on their website they wouldn't admit
that you know they're recruiting for it
and I just I yeah I just did I hated it
so um my manager said you know nobody's
done a practice desk in ages it used to
be so lucrative but it's been years it's
it's such a difficult desk and no one
wants to do it and they said we think
you'll be good at it so I grew a
practice desk from absolutely nothing
and by the time this is after year one
you did that yes this was I was a year
in and yeah by the End by a further two
years it was at
175k a year so yeah I just you know that
was I didn't Focus so much on
transactional stuff I was in a really
difficult Market where you get a
candidate and people want them yeah okay
that makes sense so practice meaning
basically external right so the group
yeah okay accountancy firm that will
service different businesses okay so let
let's talk about that then because for
you to go Laura that hates co- calling
and the Business Development which is
really common by the way I hated that I
absolutely sha my pants when I had to
start doing that it's it's you would be
good but good I no I would the thing is
so it was it was really weird right so
what I had to
overcome it's it's that bit before you
make the call so I'd always have just
not the right things having the right I
wouldn't be having the right internal
dialogue before I picked up the call and
my relationship with it wasn't right
because when I actually got free to
people I was actually all right on the
phone but it was theit before that
always prevented me from doing more of
it if you get what I mean yeah so but
even though I'd have like an okay
experience and it wasn't that bad or I
tried I did
okay I that was just my difficulty was
like the bit before that I just got in
my own head basically um but you had to
overcome that if you had to build a new
desk basically right so it hasn't been
touched for a while reads You' got you
work for a brand that's known so surely
you had to like what was the plan what
was the game plan how did you build this
from how did you build it from scratch
because it's a different Market it's
much more candidate like heavily heavily
C LED so I just had to I had to be good
at finding candidates and also building
their trust it's quite a Cy it's like
all the directors of these firms seem to
know each other they're all Old Worlds
do you like play golf together that's
that is a a massive sweeping sure I go
in yeah yeah keep know each other yeah
exactly so you really had to gain their
trust um and the things that I was good
at like writing job adverts that really
painted a picture of life and a firm you
know they didn't sound like all the
other job adverts and people responded
to me and I think I just started growing
a network and I became known as a bit
more of a specialist I wasn't just an
accountancy person um and yeah so it was
it was my other soft skills being you
know having an eye for detail being able
to write really well and being very
personable with people who maybe were a
bit uh
you know mistrustful of of recruiters of
recruiters yeah okay so so yeah play to
your strength leveraged the candidate
Network which I'm then assuming Business
Development and getting clients was
easier because what you was specking
people out basically oh yeah you call
them with you know a good practice
candidate and you just have much more
interest and then you could develop the
relationship that way they say oh Laura
sending us decent emails with decent
people and I I guess I just started
making a name for myself okay that makes
sense sense so by the end of year by the
end of that year the first year doing
the practice desk how how long did it
take you cuz one of the common questions
that I always get lur
is about building a new patch about
building a new desk and the challenges
that come with that and people's
experience so you're talking about this
now but how long did you I don't know if
it was an internal thing but how long
did you give yourself to be like right
I'm going to give us a real go for a
year year and a half before I think
about going back to something else or
whatever like what was the time frame
that you gave yourself to be like I've
given this a real good crack if if I've
got two certain Milestones by that point
then I'm going to carry on or not like
how long did it take you think to build
some momentum I just sort of from the
get-go they they basically kept me with
the we we worked on an alphabet system
so I kept the letters that I had in
Industry as like a like a bit of a
buffer and then I was just doing any
practice that I could do but I think I
just found so I never was thinking oh I
could fail at this but the practice just
started picking up so quickly that I was
then giving away letters because I
didn't want to work that stuff anymore
and I'd found but I think certainly by
the end of the first year doing practice
I must have been on about I don't know
140 150k sure really really lucrative
Market yeah so so G gathered momentum
quite quickly yeah um and was it just
you in that team then on your own just
doing practice yeah all the other girls
did Industries there were five of us in
the rest of the team why um why do you
think was you that so I know obviously
we were saying before didn't we that
obviously you won numerous awards at
Reed pretty competitive landscape why
why do you think why do you think it was
Laura Briggs that was near the top of
the leaderboard or W Awards why was it
you over other people do you think I
think I'm very good at relationship
building like you know you know being
personable you know not I never had I I
never sounded like a salesperson on a
call and I know lots of recruit don't
but you know I always I just speak the
way that I speak in real life um and I
am just I'm I'm very typ a so you know
spinning a lot of plates and being
organized and you know following up with
people when I needed to and doing what I
said I would do and you know really
having an eye for who was going to be
great at a job and those are the things
you can't really I couldn't explain how
I was good at them they're just you know
they're just your natural sort of flare
I suppose yeah no I love that so why
don't we talk about I mean where when
did you have that moment then or was
there a moment when you thought about
starting your own business have you
always thought about starting your own
business like where did that
motivational entrepreneurial Spirit come
from you know what it was because as
after two years they realized that I was
making a lot of money and they wanted in
um so there was this you know this corn
of the business that I'd grown that was
you know my it was my corner and I felt
very sort of protective of it and they
said yeah yeah thanks for that we'll uh
we'll have that back and we'll get some
more consultants in and we'll grow the
practice team and I just thought no
that's not no I'm gonna buy a phone and
a laptop and I'm sure I can do this
myself yeah that was the only that
that's the typical thought process isn't
it find lap so I can do this myself I
know I think I was such a divver in this
last meeting with um one of the senior
managers I think I just walked out I
said really yeah I just said what are
you doing I've worked so hard on this
and now you're pretty much going to
split up my desk I said what do you
think I'm going to do and I don't think
they thought I'd do it um but I did and
yeah haven't looked back okay so let's
talk about this let's talk about Laura
Briggs the the business own because it
is different right it is it is it's
completely different right it isn't it
isn't just a laptop and a
phone yeah there's a lot more to it
right which is before I started yeah I
thought it was that yeah and and that's
a common misconception right so I guess
did you so did you have any before you
did this right was it what do you was it
the complete motivation of like no you
know what I've worked really hard um and
yeah I don't want to give up things that
I've worked hard for that that was the
main driver for you to just take the
leap basically I think that's taking the
plunge and making that decision is some
is um the hardest part right so that
that was the main motivator for you it
seemed like okay cool did you have a
plan no and I was going to say that was
the that was the main thing that I would
change if I went back I I went into it
thinking oh I have to leave my job I can
do this for myself and I'm just gonna
you know I'll get a really basic website
and I'll get an accountant and I'll just
start working and see what happens if
anyone wanted to do it themselves
honestly having a plan a strategy is
everything you know that it wasn't until
18 months in that I realized I needed
that stuff yeah and you know i' just
been thinking well I just need to make
money I just need to make this work I
didn't think about what my brand was
going to be like I didn't think about
what my uh you know what activity I
wanted to focus on whether I had a
growth plan you know it was just you
know make money for myself why do you
why do you think that didn't get to the
top of the priority list until 18 months
in probably because I didn't have this
passion to start my own business it was
more of a a needs must yeah um and it
wasn't until you know I got past that
really shaky first months where you're
thinking oh God am I going to be okay
and it it was okay and then I was just
that your covenants period as well yeah
yeah six months I think yeah what six
months um and I just went you know this
is really working but I have no I'm not
answerable to anyone or anything um I
don't have any sort of personal
professional targets and I you know I'm
just making things up as I go along and
at that point that's when I sat down I
went I really need a strategy and it
changed everything really yeah let's
talk about those that early period let's
break this down into sort of the early
period because I think that that's the
part that people most worried about but
how long how long did it take you to
make your first placement a month I
think really yeah I decided to I don't
know how I decided to start working in
Plymouth because I just done Bristol and
um and the surrounds when I worked for
Reed that's where I'm based and Plymouth
became really really lucrative I mean if
they're somewhere that they don't have a
recruiter sort of monopolizing that
market then it was really easy to just
start using LinkedIn and you can find
accountants online and you it's not
difficult stuff you need to just get
people's emails or telephone numbers and
start doing what you do um and that's
the thing I know some people's markets
are different they're much more
complicated than that um but for me it
was just I'm just going to crack on I I
know how to do this yeah yeah yeah I'm
sure that helped though right I mean a
month month isn't too long right and
then and then what and then was it was
nor what happens is month and then it
might be like four months until the next
one or something like that or did it
just really regular okay fair that's
that's decent then yeah so how because
I've had to go through this right and I
think this is like how how did you deal
with no one holding you
accountable but how did you find that oh
it's it's tough because people used to
say to me oh I could never work from
home and by myself and blah blah blah I
don't know how you do it and I was
thinking well I find it really hard as
well you do get used to it but it's just
so unsettling it's just even when things
are going right it just it doesn't feel
it doesn't feel natural and I think if
I'd sat down and I had this plan and I
had this vision of what the business was
going to be and a real structure around
what my business was you know I wasn't
under Reed's sort of hat anymore I was
under my own and I didn't make anything
out of that you know I had a logo and I
had a Wix website and that was pretty
much it um but I think I would have had
so much more self-belief um if I had you
know sat down and got right what is
Laura Briggs the brand and how what are
we what are we trying to achieve what
are you trying to achieve yeah and and
and those early stages in Laura how did
you deal with if if any did you how did
you deal with the
self-doubt I think I just I just threw
myself into it I I think I think I'm
pretty I'm pretty resilient probably but
I just knew that I wanted it to work and
I knew that I really didn't want to go
back to an agency people kept saying you
know if it doesn't work out you can go
back to an a but once I made that first
placement oh there's just there is
nothing like suddenly that that money is
just sat in your account you're not get
just getting you know Commission on your
salary check you and it was like it was
like my job went from black and white to
techy color I just went I just shown
that I can people pay me money for this
yeah doesn't feel real does it the no no
it's it it's a it's a pride that you
don't even have on your biggest month
when you work for an agency yeah yeah
how what was your support network like
out of interest cuz I think that that's
helped me a lot and I think people going
out on their own like that it can be
quite lonely but what was your support
network like did you have suppored
friends partner whatever that you think
helped yeah so I um I live with my
fiance so I had him around although
obviously the days are lonely I tried
working in cafes and things but that
didn't really work for me really um but
yeah I think I think because everybody
was so shocked that I did it that I was
just I think just being motivated to
prove to people that I could yeah I
think so that yeah sounds really a
really arrogant way of thinking but I
just you know no one wants to
fail okay so what made what made you
take a step back and basically think on
the business basically which is what you
did because I think when you are a a
business of you or very small business
it's it's so easy to just get caught in
what you're doing you know what you need
to do in the business yeah but what what
made you sort of go hang on a minute I
do need to think about Laura Briggs the
brand and what I'm trying to achieve
here was there a particular moment or
what dve that do you think yeah I was on
holiday abroad last September and you
know sometimes when you're not at home
you can really put eyes on things and I
just I was dreading going back home I
knew that my work was it was coming in
but I felt absolutely no enthusiasm
about anything and I just started
researching and I can't remember how I
came I came across you pretty early on
though I mean your personal branding
thing was like a turning point and I
suddenly just realized oh I you know I
need to brand myself and I need I know
who I am and what's great about me but
nobody else knows and my business just
needs an injection of you know a bit of
personality and some advertising and
that's when I got into all this personal
branding and then I started a big big
marketing project that has well has got
me to where I am now really yeah CU I
think your website is Awesome by the way
thanks and no like genuinely I I do
really believe that and I think um I
think you're right especially when your
names attached to your business right
sure like a person person yeah that's
what I mean person that's what I mean so
I guess let's talk about this so within
so marketing was a big part so I'd love
to sort of dig into that with you and
because I think a lot of people do know
it's important but have no idea where to
start so I'd love to sort of talk to you
about your journey with that but what
else sort of coincided with that Laura
did you did you make that time to go
okay well why am I doing this what what
is the goal like do I want to grow do I
not want to grow what am I did you also
think about those things during that
period as well yeah at that point I knew
that I still didn't want to be a big
business I I've I think a lot of my
value was in being small and I just
thought it feels feels like so much more
risk when I've got a lot of growing
still to do as a Onan band to then think
I'm going to start hiring people and
you've got so many other considerations
once you've got a team so I thought you
know I really have a vision of of what I
can do by myself and I started setting
you know professional goals and tracking
all this marketing activity and things
with my website and you know I had a
Content plan and suddenly my weeks
became so much more structured and
everything just fell into place and you
could do that from the beginning you
know you don't have to you have to wait
until you are you know completely lost
your way like I had to do that that at
the start so so how how did what how did
you start then let's just talk about
that because I think a lot of people can
be paralyzed by I have no idea where to
start and these things but like by this
point was was was you doing everything
like was you doing all the the accounts
like did you was you using any other
sort of resource or like what yeah
everything was myself I yeah I had a I
had what more of my accountants um doing
my accounts and yeah that was it no no I
did everything myself and I enjoyed that
because sometimes it's nice to have a
break from recruitment to you know do
some sort of you know admin or that kind
of thing so I was I was happy to do it
um but this was just a shift to to
include Marketing in there and I can't
tell you like marketing yourself is as
important as the recruitment itself it's
it's crazy how much it's changed
things so how did you start how did you
start the journey then because I'm sure
you would have been like right where do
I start what what did you what did you
start with genuinely it's not just CU
you're here I genuinely think I found I
stumbled across you and that's when
personal branding was you sort of the
first time I learned about it okay I
started researching that I then thought
you well if I'm going to have a personal
brand I need to be shouting about it and
there had been this really cool design
Agency in Bristol that I wanted to work
with at the start to get my logo but I
just couldn't afford them and I thought
I'm going to get an absolutely smashing
website done by them so I created this
brand I did all the background work I
learned from you about content marketing
well about let's just the background
work what sort of things did you do
what' you mean so you said did all the
background work before sure yeah what
sort of things I looked at how you build
a brand so you know looking at you know
your business vision and your strategy
and your individual goals that are going
to get you there and how you're going to
Market yourself and what your what your
brand personality is and how you want
your customers to see you aw basically
just create just created Laura bricks
this Laura bricks the brand um and I
really got behind it and because it's
yourself you're not having to create
something you were just saying all the
things I'm good at I want to be able to
you know I want people to buy into that
and how what how I've done that for
myself but like how did that help you
because I think sometimes they're
questions that people don't make the
time to ask like how do I want my
customers to feel when I work with them
and what is
my vision like how did that that how did
that help you is it's it's definitely
it's not something you you can just sit
down and and come up with but I think
over the course of you know maybe a
month or so of just thinking what is it
that I really focus on what is different
about my service and why do the people
who work with me come back to me well
it's you know because I'm a specialist
I'm really good at what I do I'm nice to
work with I'm not pushy um I'm very
personable and that helps you know once
you've got that down suddenly it's much
easier to think oh this is what my
business is yeah I love that and for me
that it's just I don't know I think it's
just so important just to know what the
vision is for me that that just always
helps when you have those days which
it's difficult or you're having
challenges or whatever it's just great
to have that Anchor Point and actually
make the time to think about it yeah um
so okay and learn about content
marketing great and then obviously
engaged with this design agency and then
what you started the website the website
project
yeah so the website was it was a it was
a a real expense for me but I just you
know I just had faith that this was what
was going to propel me and the idea was
that I was going to do content marketing
on LinkedIn that was going to drive
people to my website they were going to
love my website I had free resources
that I created that they could sign up
to an email list I was then you know
doing blogs every week that would get
sent to my email list um and that way I
was going to get people to know and
trust
and and like me and that was going to
bring in sort of more business to me
sort of proactively love that how long
did it take for the website to be done
what how long did that project take uh
it started at the end of November and
finished mid January had to the launch
mid January and I had you know I had
like a professional photo shoot I was so
out of my comfort zone but it just I
just knew I was doing the right thing
really yeah what so was it just was it
just that internal dialogue that helped
you do that CU that is that is isn't
that isn't yeah a lot of people are
uncomfortable with that was it just like
I know I'm doing the right but you had
no one to tell you you doing the right
thing no but you were writing things on
on LinkedIn that were basically saying
look stop talking about your jobs no one
cares about your jobs they care about
you and if they like you and they trust
you and you talk about the way that you
do things that is what's going to want
to make them work with you not oh I have
a job um and that I just knew as soon as
I read that that was exactly where I was
going wrong okay so that was was that
January this year was that yeah yeah J
January this year the website launched
yeah how did it go oh it's yeah been
amazing it's been like I think the first
LinkedIn post that I did after launching
I got like a h over hundred likes on it
and so all these messages and people
going to the website and so much good
feedback and I just thought God if
that's day one you know this is this is
totally going to be worth it
how so like how did you obviously I'm
assuming before that you wasn't sharing
much content at all not at all no I'm
one of those people who you know even
when I used to have a Facebook account
like I'd never do a status you know it's
really I'm really you know bit more of a
shrinking violet online um but I decided
that I was going to do a blog post that
I would post to LinkedIn every Thursday
um that was like a you know a question
and then me answering it and then doing
a blog post about it and then on a
Tuesday was going to do something that
was either you know something that
happened to me something that was
relevant to business something was
talking about stuff that I understood
about clients or candidates something
that was personable um and that's been
my that's been my strategy ever since
really nice yeah love that what what's
what's happened since you've done this
that you didn't
expect well one I'm so much more
invested in my business I'm much prouder
of it even though I was you know always
doing well now it's a business business
that I feel proud of love that um and
yeah I I guess the other thing is that
people come to me I don't chase down
work anymore like it people just email
me wanting help or they want me to work
their jobs or and that is just you know
I get lots of
recommendations that is that is the
dream I think really as a recruiter not
to have to do do a lot of the chasing
how long and how long did you did that
take you think like for you to get to a
point where I don't know if you get
regular sort of people saying hey Laura
can you help or whatever like how long
did that actually take probably about
four months I mean it was it was a bit
strange because obviously um the the
pandemic and lockdown and everything hit
um but that's the thing I I haven't felt
it at all it's it's been fine really
okay so four months I mean that's still
a good amount of time it's a time that I
will speak to people about in terms of I
mean that's a long enough time to give
it a real good
go how something I always get Laura I'm
Keen to get your thoughts on this
because I've seen your posts and and
some of them are personal very human
which is great how have you dealt with
any
negativity you mean comments wise
yeah people people always worried about
that when I when I speak to people they
they they're really worried about
getting buried online yeah but you're
not there to be controversial you're
there to be relatable you know that sell
by creating some sort of emotion in
people by either them going oh that is
exactly how I feel or yeah I get that or
oh I feel strongly about that you aren't
trying to be oh I'm just going to say
something that's going to get people
talking and I think if you have an
opinion that you think might be
controversial you follow up with a you
know this is what I think do you think
the same am I wrong about this you know
I think just be a little bit more
humble fair so it hasn't really phased
you I don't I don't think I'm putting
out stuff that that people can really
kick back out very much I have a couple
see occasionally get the Grump grumpy
old uh director or something comenting
Ki about that that's fair enough so um
so what what would your advice be then
to people listening that that we know
this is important they know branding is
important but having no idea where to
start they're not not sure what to do
like just from your learnings and the
journey that you've been on
what what would your advice be you think
so I would say that you just want to
create a p you just want to be a
three-dimensional recruiter you're not
somebody who just CHS out jobs you are
someone with a personality and everyone
has a personality so you can just start
on LinkedIn you know that everyone that
you want is on LinkedIn start talking
about things that aren't jobs um talk
about the way that you do recruitment um
talk about what you love about your job
um you know a candidate that you've
spoken to um anything that is very yeah
relatable and and real and just you just
have to be honest and and also not worry
too much about the numbers because at
first you can think oh God my my post
didn't get enough likes it wasn't worth
it but people will see it and you just
you just need to
persevere okay and how how does this now
fit in your sort of weekly week then
Laura compared to getting on the phone
building relationships like what I don't
know how if you were to split your week
into like percentages like because I
think this is the part I always speak to
people about building your brand Etc
isn't to replace the phone in my opinion
it it just isn't that it's about adding
it to your toolbox of skills and having
a yeah multi- Channel approach to
building your desk and your business
yeah so like what what's been your
experience of that and how have you like
how do you tend to split your week
because clearly you're doing a lot of
content you invested in it it's it's
working for you but how have you made it
fit into your week with everything else
that you're doing and yeah how does that
look look like I would probably say
content is probably about 35% of it but
I've always seen it as you know if I if
I get the right people invested in me
then I I can do the rest of it that's
you know the recruitment isn't the
involved or difficult side of things
it's it's it's finding people um and so
I think because of how much easier it's
made things during the lockdown um and
how many people have come to me I've
realized the value of you know I really
do need to keep investing that at least
a third of my time in marketing myself
okay interesting so let let's talk about
the last couple of months then was you
worried going into it yeah I I'd had a
few quite a few good months before so I
what I just thought you know I can ride
this out it's it's not a great great
situation but then I so I just decided
I'm going to step back from this I want
to be sensitive I don't think this is
the right time to be contacting you know
businesses who might be struggling and
um but but people kept contacting me
saying I've been made made redundant and
so I'd send out the you know speak to um
clients or send send them emails that
were very sensitive in nature that I
understood that I didn't want this to
land wrong um I didn't want to come
across the wrong way but I was helping
people who' made redundant and the
response was brilliant I think they like
the fact that I was you know being aware
of what was going on but accountancy was
still sort of running you know not all
firms were busy but plenty of them were
and I think once I'd been placing a few
people people knew that I was still open
for business and yeah everything just
just ticked along really she just did
the right
thing again it's just it's just thinking
with your head isn't it just sometimes
not being oh I'm A salesperson and this
is what I do it's going you know is this
the right time to be emailing someone or
if I have to contact somebody at the
moment how am I going to go about it in
a way that you know shows them that I
understand that you know there are
bigger things going on at the moment
yeah being empathetic just being a human
yeah doing the right it goes it's it's
just that's been one of my biggest
learnings over the last year and a bit
is like that goes so far in business
yeah like it really it really does like
it it resonates with people people um
like to work with people that feel like
they understand them and it's actually
can be one of your biggest assets
definitely and you sometimes it's the
smallest thing that you do or say that
makes people think oh that's just bit
different like I've never heard I've
never heard a recruiter say that or do
that and suddenly you're you know
propelled up in their estimation and you
know it's it really is the little things
how did you feel because I know we spoke
about this like obviously unfortunately
there's been uh loads of people made
redundant um people in fur which comes
with its own challenges like as a a
business of just Laura and you like how
what where was your head at I don't know
how has it made you feel about having
your own business do you think during
this period well just just knowing that
people I still know at read so many of
them have been fured and I guess it's I
guess it's just luck because I would be
in exactly the same situation um if if I
was still at an agency um but that's the
thing you know you have so much more
freedom um within a business to either
step back or carry on going or you know
you you know you're dancing to the beat
of your own
drum yeah that that's that's definitely
cuz cuz I think look you always hear
about read any business book it's
normally around growing your business
scaling all these things but I think the
last couple of months has really shown
to me that there's there's a lot of
value in being a Nimble agile small
business right yeah I I would hate
anybody to be sitting there thinking oh
if I start a recruitment business you
because I probably sat in an agency
thinking if I start my own recruitment
business you know it's I've got to be
able to grow a business you don't you
can have a really lucrative really
successful really enjoyable recruitment
business business just yourself and you
always have the option to grow it if you
want want to but I've just been finding
it so rewarding so far Never Say Never
but is is that being the main reason why
you have you have decided to or yeah why
you it is still just you do you think
it's so flexible and it depends you know
I know people who they just you know
went in their garden shed for the first
two years and they just worked and they
you know hired people and they built and
that just isn't for me and I don't feel
that that you know is any reflection on
me I'm just I'm just different and I
want to be successful in a different way
and I want to I want my work to be
flexible as well yeah no I love that how
have you during this you as a business
owner then Laura have you have you made
time to invest in yourself like because
you seem as you seem someone that's got
resilience you got a good head on your
shoulders like I don't know I how what's
that Journey been like in terms of
mindset because that's that's a big part
of going out on your own doing these
things like have you made time to always
invest in Laura and yourself or what
what's been your journey with
that um yeah I don't I think with with
your business sort of coming together
that that becomes part of your identity
I know that it shouldn't but you know if
you have you have your own business that
a certain confidence comes from having
done that um but I don't know I think
some of it's some of it's tough I think
what I've really been shaken is is when
you know you're treated badly by clients
and I've actually had a few wobbles
where I've thought you know maybe
recruitment isn't for me you do have to
be quite thick skinned um but I've got
much better at walking away from things
that aren't you I can choose who I work
with now I think that's the thing when
you're in agency you just think I have
to deal with every every bone I get
thrown and you don't and as a you know
when you're working for yourself you
have to be a bit Kinder you have to say
look if if that person's causing me
stress it's not worth it you don't work
for
anything because that that's what I was
going to that was going to be my next
question for you like what what have
been the biggest challenges for you
since doing this like what what so yeah
dealing with customers that stressed you
out or it's been difficult but like what
what have been what have been some of
the challenges that you've had to
overcome do you think or the biggest
ones yeah I think I think being small
sometimes people feel that they can take
advantage of you um I I you having
really really watertight terms and going
about everything in a really meticulous
way I've learned
from a couple of couple of sticky
situations there um but I don't know I
it's just one of those things you you
naturally grow and become more business
savvy and um you know with a better idea
of what's serving you and what isn't and
there's no there aren't necessarily
those points along the way that you know
completely change the way you do things
but it it's just running your own
business it is just a natural growth
curve yeah it's interesting to say about
terms of business because that's such
like a really practical it comes up a
lot I've had quite a few messages around
that how did you make sure that they did
become watertight was it just engaging
with a proper lawyer and doing that
rather other because no one typically
you would I've always spoke to people on
on here a couple times i' be like yeah
I've never had to put together terms of
business that was a learn that I had to
go through like yeah but you will um
you'll have obviously use terms that
your uh agency uses and to be honest
they all read the same um my dad had
some that he'd been he's a finance
director that he had some from other
agencies and I just compared them and
they all had exactly the same Clauses
but then when it came to using them I
had a couple of situations where I think
I was taken advantage of by firms and
when I went to see a specialist
recruitment lawyer he was then able to
advise me on how to send things what to
say and what Clauses to include but I
still think in law recruitment is uh
massively disadvantage advantaged so
You' just got to be very careful about
the way you work and and that yeah
probably just got a few St stung maybe
two or three times by that in the first
year or two yeah yeah okay interesting
so what how how are you viewing the so
it's been obviously since January that
you had this big project that obviously
now we've gone through Co like how are
you how are you viewing the next six to
12 months what what's what do the future
look
like that's a really good question just
more I'm just enjoying it now so I I
spoke to a client the other day who said
you know you could be hiring people you
know now that you have a brand and this
works and you know people buy into it
there's no reason you couldn't hire
people and I was
like just
couldn't that was my head
exploding um I just thought yeah I I
could do that and I wasn't in a position
to do it before because I you know was
just somebody who still felt like I you
know had that laptop on the phone but
now my business feels a lot more
tangible and that's what I'm going to be
thinking about on this holiday when I
get away I do all my
strategizing what what's what's made it
feel more
tangible because now it's got like it's
that's the thing a brand makes your
business more than just a bank account
and a series of emails yeah now if I
said Laura Briggs recruitment you know
you can Google me you can look at my
Google reviews you can see me on maps
you can look at my website you can read
my content you can sign up to my mailing
list um and I have created like a
personality around who I am and what I
do and if somebody was to join me now I
would know how to induct them into that
if that makes sense I would just be like
right you need a laptop and a phone just
just get on the get on the phone yeah
yeah I know what you mean what what what
just just out of interest if like
anything that you're worried about to
when hiring someone do you
think yeah I think well I've heard that
um managing people is mostly just
dealing with people's personal personal
so you know like half of it is
doing the job and half of it is you know
everything else and I think you could
open a can of worms but that is the only
way to really you know further your
business you know be I've got a finite
amount of time but you know to really go
further in business you you need other
people working with you as well I think
I think it's probably the next
challenge and have you managed people
before no never and it's never appealed
to me at all I think I'm quite you know
I'm a lone wolf I just like you know
getting on with my own thing but I yeah
I think I could do it love that like to
think I'd be a good
manager hopefully yeah um what I was
going to say
so just just out of Interest as well
like it's something that I obviously how
have you dealt
with like when you work for reading in
an agency you have people to celebrate
wins with you have people to say hey
I've done this what do you think or
whatever like how has that been for you
because I I've I've had to I mean I've
gone out of my way to to lean on people
and theyve acted as mentors in the way
but like what what's that been like for
you and have you met or engaged or built
relationships with anyone that has sort
of given you that outlet or have you not
no I didn't at all and it's only since I
did this Rebrand and I've had people I
don't even know reaching out to me and
that you know just being so
complimentary about the things that I'm
doing but before then remember my fiance
used to say to me um you know oh you've
made a placement shall we you know
celebrate and I'd say well do you
celebrate now do you celebrate when they
hand in the notice do you celebrate when
they start do you celebrate after their
three month preparation period so I just
never you know and even a year in you're
thinking okay I've done a good year but
can I do another good year it's yeah I I
I think I'm very I'm very cautious by
Nature do you find it hard to give
yourself
credit yeah probably because the things
that you're good at are the things that
just you don't have to work very hard to
do you know I focus on the things that
I'm not so good at and I think you know
um one of my my friend's husband he
started like a really successful
recruitment business and it's like
turnover in the millions now and you
think is that what I should be I really
had a bit of soul searching where I said
just because that's not what I want it
doesn't mean that what I have isn't
great you know I'm really proud of what
I have and I I do have a very successful
business it's just it's only me yeah no
I love that I think I'm I'm sure you've
heard this before but it always
resonates with me when I hear it but
comparison is the thief of Joy right so
you can always get caught in that
content you can always get caught in oh
wow they look like they and especially
in like as a recruitment business like
oh they've got all these people they're
doing well blah blah blah but with that
they're all they're completely different
headaches that you won't be dealing with
right now and it's it's not as do you
know what I mean but I find that hard as
well to give myself credit I've been in
those situation where my girlfriend
would be like right let's go for dinner
celebrate and I'm be like yeah but I
don't know it just feels a bit weird
doesn't it I find it hard it's it's
difficult and I think I don't know I
think I'm very mindful of it I think I'm
very mindful of not getting caught up in
off my Supply basically because I I
think it's just really important to stay
grounded yes you should let people
praise you and that's great but I don't
know I think when I'm just always aware
of getting caught
in people bigging me up and I live like
that's I don't know I'm I'm just very
wary of that yeah and I I think it
depend it depends what resonates with
you as well for me I mean being a
recruiter placements just become you
know they are they are how you make
money how you invest in your business
they don't become oh my goodness every
time I make some money that's a cause
for celebration I think for me it's much
more it's people it's feedback from
people people saying that they love
working for me my Google reviews am my
happy place you know those kind of
things um and I yeah I just think that's
a reflection of of you know the fact
that I want a business that you know I
want want to be someone that people
enjoy working with so when I hear that
that's my affirmation yeah no I love
that um cool so look before we
finish I just wanted to to say and and
ask you what what are you well actually
no what what I wanted to get your
thoughts on before you finish
is how do you think the sort of land's
going to lay 6 to 12 months from now
during the covid period there's going to
be a lot of changes like what are you
keeping your eye on or what what do you
think or what are your thoughts on what
the future of recruitment might look
like in the next six 12 months because
from what I can see I think there's
going to be a lot of changes which are
going to be interesting but anything
that sort of you Noti is picking up on
or seeing that you're interested to see
how it plans out I think if anyone's
thinking about going off on their own I
think now is the time to do it I think
the focus on recruitment is going to be
less on you know it's easy you can Chuck
CVS around you know you work for a big
agency and you know you it's just easy
to be a top biller I think now it's
going to be much more about the quality
of your service you know the devil is in
the detail everything from the way you
write your job adverts to that you know
the whole client experience when when
somebody works with you you know not
just the end result did you make a
placement but how did I make them feel
would they come back to me loyalty I
think that is I think I hope we're going
to turn our reputation as recruiters
around just because we're all much more
aware of that yeah I think it's a great
point that you raised because I think if
you're not those things that you just
said the chances of you surviving the
last three four months I'd like to think
are quite slim right because I think I
think a lot of people from what I could
see anyway there's a lot of people that
are passionate about recruitment like
you are and changing the reputation and
doing the right thing before we went
into Co for sure but there's still a lot
of people that just you'll know this
more than me because you'll probably
come up against it but people just
sending CVS and it's still very
transactional and delivering a
service to clients and candidates but I
feel like the last three four months has
probably sped up those people not
existing yeah because because you're
right it's like if you're not those
things and you're not a
consultant during this period what sort
of relationships are you going to form
or have coming out of like do you know
what I mean so I think It sped all of
that up I think yeah there's there's
just been a magnifying glass on
recruitment I think because so many more
people have made redundant so many
businesses are failing I just think
we've really this is a good chance for
us to step up our game and for the
people who who are different to to
really stand out yeah for sure so look
Laura absolute pleasure I did all right
didn't I oh no we're still we're still
on camera don't celebrate yet but um Ju
Just parting words really I guess yeah I
know you sort of touched on it but
parting words for people listening
um it could be anything around starting
their going out starting their own
recruitment business or just being a
recruiter sort of what would you say to
the people if they'd listen to Laura
Briggs and they take on your advice what
what would you say I'd say get on the
content strategy you know start writing
stuff that isn't jobs um up up your job
advert writing game because that's
everything and uh yeah if you're
thinking about leaving definitely do it
I would definitely have done it sooner
if I if I you know with hindsight Laura
thank you thank you